I love that term alchemical marriage
because I think a lot in sexuality we
think of chemistry between two people
but I'm less interested in chemistry I'm
more interested in the Alchemy between
two people the intention in coming
together with another person is how do
we create Alchemy we're in a really
powerful place I love that you use
alchemical Union for describing this
very powerful experience that we can
have through sexuality I think one of
the reasons why we live in such a
polarized state is because in the
polarized state we get to play a
different game it's like through
polarity that we actually learn who we
truly are sometimes and I also think
it's through polarity that we have the
universe that we have we have a
dichotomy within us that we're exploring
because if we're always in in Union then
we don't get to explore I always say
it's so lucky that we have these bodies
and then we get to
explore sensation and touch and taste
and through the senses